So casting is probably a concept that you're already pretty familiar with
But as with things like the the standard pointer library and just a lot of the standard template library
Unreal actually has its own implementations of these things, which we encourage you to use. So let's just look into that a little bit
So first off we have object is a
Essentially, this is what the function that you would call when you want to check
Purely whether a thing is another thing whether a class is actually a child of this is other type of class
Not when you need access to that classes information
But you just purely want to perform that check the kind of step up from that is the cast templated type T
And this is when you would be both checking. It's like a dynamic cast
It's when you are both checking for whether or not this object matches that type. But also if it does you get back a
An instance a copy of that variable with that type or a null pointer if it wasn't that type
And that's the kind of more complicated version
T cat the templated form of cast does essentially perform is a
under the hood
So again slightly less performant because it's a couple more steps if you only need the binary check for whether or not this is
a thing you don't need access to its data then I would it's preferable to use is a for slightly better performance
Exact cast it checks whether it is precisely this type not whether it is a child of this type, but whether the types match exactly
And last of all we have cast checked. This is essentially a
slightly more performant version of cast where if it
Fails to that cast then you would get a crash
so
But it performs an is a at editor time at development time, but actually in a shipping build
It doesn't perform that is a check you would just get a it would just crash
So this is this can this is used for a couple of reasons a it's slightly more performant because that is a is pulled out
Of the of the flow in shipping builds, but also it kind of conveys intention
cast checked is something that you would
You would use in code when you want some two things to be very very tightly linked to say I don't want this to
Be optional this needs to be this thing
So an example of that might be the behavior tree component in the AI controller
Nothing else should be in that pointer. So you can be is essentially saying, you know, this needs to be this thing